foreign
[Music]
goes sharing is caring and that's
exactly what shared vpcs are all about
this video will show you how to
troubleshoot and dissolve common issues
when creating and managing shared vpcs
to begin let's take a quick look at some
shared VPC Concepts shared VPC allows an
organization to connect resources from
multiple projects to a common shared
virtual private Cloud Network so they
can communicate securely and efficiently
using internal IPS from that Network
typically in shared VPC there will be a
host project to which you can attach one
or more service projects
VPC networks and the host projects are
referred to as shared VPC Networks
resources in the service projects
attached to a host project using the
same shared VPC Network can communicate
with one another using their internal IP
addresses subject to firewall rules
keep in mind shared VPC uses a security
model where organization administrators
get to maintain control over network
resources like subnets routes and
firewalls but the delegate are the
responsibilities like creating and
managing instances to service project
admins
okay
for this shared VPC requires the
following IM administrative rules
shared VPC admin which has the compute
shared VPC admin and project IM admin
roles for the organization or at least
one folder this enables them to perform
various tasks necessary to set off
shared VPC such as enabling host
projects attaching or detaching service
projects to host projects and in most
cases a shared VPC admin is typically
the project owner for a given host
service project admin to Grant a service
project admin the shared VPC admin needs
to Grant an IM principal the network
user role for the whole host project or
subnets that are a part of the cdpc
networks
they maintain ownership and control over
resources in the service projects so
they should have the instance admin role
for the service projects they may also
have additional IM rules for the service
projects such as being the project owner
today I will show you how to
troubleshoot and resolve common issues
absorbed while configuring or managing
the shared VPC let's start with the
first problem
when a user attempts to set up host
project in shared VPC it fails with the
following error you do not have
sufficient permission to view this page
as indicated here the error occurs due
to the lack of
compute.projects.get and
resourcemanager.projects.getim policy
permissions by the user or service
account performing the task
to resolve the issue ensure the user or
service account is assigned with compute
shared VPC admin and project IM admin
roles or the shared VPC admin role which
will have the required permissions to
access the shared VPC page and set up
the host project
now let's look at the second issue where
we will try to create a VM in a service
project using one of the shared VPC
subnets let's assign a shared VPC
Network to a VM
the shared subnet drop down menu is
grayed out and we are seeing an error
unable to fetch subnets in this region
when you click on the intended Dropbox
these error occur because the user
doesn't have the compute.network user
role to access the specific subnets to
resolve this issue go to the IM and
admins page for the host project and
ensure the user is a service project
admin and is granted with the role of
compute.network user for the selected
subnets in the specific host projects
finally let's look at the last issue
let's detach a service project from the
shared VPC
oh no it's failing
as denoted in the error this resource is
still linked to the shared VPC host
hence we are unable to detach the
project
to be able to detach a service project
all the resources in the specific
project using the shared VPC subnets
must be deleted
to resolve this issue the required
resources from the specific service
project must be deleted before detaching
it
for more information about the shared
VPC IM rules check out the following
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]